>> The role of CFO
has changed dramatically.
CFOs were supposed to be experts in
accounting and finance,
now in dynamic environments.
They are expected to be experts
in strategy, as well.
[MUSIC]
>> I need it a course that will
help me to become a better CFO.
>> The ability to become more
engaged in financial matters with
our company was an opportunity for
advancement.
>> We expose the participants
to experts at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business who have done
research in the area of leadership,
as well as strategic thinking.
The participants,
by engaging with these experts as
well as amongst themselves, will be
able to learn these attributes and,
in a way that helps accelerate
their path becoming the CFO.
>> I've moved from the technical
aspects of being a finance
professional to a strategic partner
and I was looking for
a class that would help me jump
to the next level.
>> We want the participants to gain
a greater understanding of current
trends in finance and technology.
Develop a long-term vision and
appreciate strategy frameworks,
assess and enhance their personal
leadership style to be change
agents that drive innovation and
lead to cultural change in their
organizations.
>> Here at Stanford,
they give you the best of the best
of what is happening in
the world of finance in strategy.
>> I'm going to take back
a different attitude,
a different perspective.
>> It's not only the professor's,
the lectures, the cases, but
also the whole environment.
>> The ECFO program has been
a fantastic opportunity for me.
>> This program is supporting me in
every way not only me,
it will support my organization.
>> It has been a transformational
experience.